and Slovakia has joined Poland and
Hungary in suspending grain and other
food imports from Ukraine they say the
cheap Ukrainian grain is driving down
local prices European Union officials
have now announced that they will be
meeting this week to discuss Ukraine
grain export issues in within the block
the Polish ban followed protests by
Farmers there and the resignation of the
agriculture Minister well Charles
Stratford is live in Kiev Charles this
all seems like an unintended consequence
of this grain export deal explain to us
how we got here
yeah it's a it's a complex process and
certainly an indication of mounting
pressure on Ukraine by its European
partners that up until now have done so
they say everything that they can to try
and help Ukraine in its war with Russia
this deal unfolded as a result of some
Black Sea ports being blocked after
Russia's Invasion which of course
stopped the export of millions of tons
of Ukraine's grain and food products to
its uh markets around the world the
poles now the slovaks also the
hungarians and the Romanians now also
the Romanians intimating that they may
do the same
because apparently so much of this
Ukrainian grain has got stuck in
bottlenecks logistical problems as it's
been exported via the land Roots out of
Ukraine it is seriously depreciated the
prices of local grain and food products
in their neighboring allies in Ukraine's
neighboring allies and as you say we've
seen protests in Poland the resignation
of the Polish agricultural Minister and
we understand that there are ongoing
talks between the Ukrainian officials
Ukrainian agricultural Minister and
officials in Warsaw as they try and
negotiate a reopening of this transit
route now this is a temporary ban we
understand certainly according to the
polls they're saying this is a temporary
ban until June the 30th but yeah it is
an indication of the kind of pressure
that domestic populations in Ukraine's
Western allies those countries are
facing the governments in these
countries are facing as they try and
accommodate and help Ukraine as much as
possible because of course this grain is
a vital revenue for the ukrainians as
they uh as they try and fight the
Russians after the invasion so where
those talks ongoing we understand that
there are going to be more talks in
Slovakia and Romania in the days ahead
so there's mounting discontent aimed at
this green export deal coming from EU
Western countries but of course this is
already coming on top of existing
discontent against the deal by from
Russia
yeah there is increasing pressure From
Russia with respect to the uh the export
of Ukrainian foodstuffs grain and um the
export of Russian exports via the the
Black Sea this was a deal or a couple of
deals that uh that were signed in July
that were brokered by the U.N and turkey
the Russians are saying that they will
pull out potentially from their side of
the agreement if demands that they are
made that they are making are not met
this deal is supposed to be renewed
every 120 days it's due for renewal on
May the 18th the Russians say that they
may pull out if a whole host of Demands
are not made these include for example
Russian ships getting full access to
Ports around the world there are huge
problems so the Russians say with
Maritime insurance and they also want
restrictions to be lifted on
agricultural Machinery that Russia says
it so desperately needs
um so yeah we not only are seeing
increasing pressure by the Russians with
respect to the Ukrainian export deal via
the Black Sea but now the land Roots via
Ukraine's European partners and Charles
Stratford reporting from Kiev thank you